c'est dans cette école pour filles de la
petite ville de daqing située dans le
nord-est du nigeria que plusieurs
étudiantes ont été kidnappés c'était le
matin dit cette étudiante on était en
train de manger quand on a entendu des
coups de feu
j'ai pu m'enfuir mais d'autres filles
ont été enlevés ces rapts ont jeté la
consternation parmi la population
en plus les autorités ont été incapables
de s'entendre sur le nombre d'étudiantes
enlevés nous comptons sur les
responsables de l'école pour nous dire
combien d'élèves montent à la thèse 17
policiers mais les chiffres ne sont pas
sur certaines sont peut-être encore
réfugiés dans la forêt
ces disparitions ravivent les craintes
que l'enlèvement de 276 jeune fille de
la ville de shit box par le groupe
djihadiste boko haram avait suscité en
c'est terrible ce qui se passe dit cette
responsable du mouvement bring back à
rogers
nous ne sommes pas encore remis des
enlèvements de 2014
cent douze filles sont toujours en
captivité et voilà qu'il y à d'autres
kidnapping ces nouveaux enlèvements
représente un véritable camouflet pour
le gouvernement qui avait promis de
mettre un terme aux agissements de boko
haram
il faut comprendre que boko haram et sur
sa faim dit il ces enlèvements c'est son
chant du cygne
ils cherchent uniquement la publicité
le groupe djihadiste mène depuis 2009
une insurrection sanglante dans le
nord-est du nigeria qui a fait plus de
vingt mille morts et deux millions six
cent mille déplacés ici faller et
nikolov radio-canada mont royal